und es werden demnächst da
wahrscheinlich die ersten t shirts
tatsächlich herauskommt willkommen zu
einem neuen und wir spielen heute job
down auf kraft games punkt eu zum
zweiten mal in diesem spielmodus beim
letzten mal
beim letzten mal habe ich mich an meinen
vater vorgestellt
ok krass eigentlich gar kein abgleiten
bin momentan müsse erst wieder fuß
fassen
zack so hier nummer zwei zweites mal
eine aufnahme auf und fliegt sehr schön
alt wieder sind da unten
was ist los mit euch älter die leute die
menschen sind so krass guck mal wie weit
da unten schon sind leute es gibt ein
paar sachen anzukündigen und zwar nummer
eins heute abend wird es um 8 einen live
stream geben mal wieder seitdem ich ein
bisschen länger pause gemacht haben der
uni so viel zu tun habe ich hab es nicht
weniger zu tun habe ich denn mal fackel
beziehungsweise ich hätte heute montag
frei und kann endlich mal alles machen
was es so zu erledigen gehabt
ihr wisst nicht was ich da alles
aufgestaut hat irgendwie ich hatte jetzt
irgendwie eineinhalb wochen immer ein
zimmer kein licht weil ich keine zeit
hatte eine glühbirne zu kaufen und so
war schon da war schon wild ich einfach
keinen bock hatte nach der unions nummer
raus zug fahren müsse ein bisschen gas
geben war es über die sind krass alter
wo man richtig ab man riskiert so runde
nummer zwei liebe leute wir sind back
again und die allererste sache wie
gesagt mit dem steam wurde soweit
angekündigt übrigens diese runden hier
bei jump da unser spiel modus bei dem
man versuchen muss möglich sein nach
unten zu kommen nicht von hinten
geflogen zu werden
sie stehen da schon gehen relativ kurz
die daumen gar nicht lange da ein paar
minuten oder so dass st
kollege ist angeschlagen aber ich nicht
doch weit gefehlt die schlagen mich doch
jetzt muss schnell in eine nein egal ja
ja ja ich musste ganz schnell weg ich
muss hier ganz schnell weg am besten
nach unten
zum beispiel hier hin das geht alles
klar so nächste sache leute das merge
ist in arbeit das wollte ich nicht sagen
darüber will ich euch bescheid geben
okay
berlin auch relativ schnell dauern ich
habe mich mit chris zusammengesetzt
dingen kennt ihr vielleicht der hat auch
an maxis also anis merge mitgearbeitet
ojo komm rüber kommen kubaner kosten
nicht er hat und aktiv mitgearbeitet und
der hat sich längst aufgegangen
meist die nase gefallen so heißt es hier
der hat sich dann auch mit mir mal
zusammengesetzt und wer ein paar coole
coole coole ideen entwickelt sehr schön
und als einiges herbei herumgekommen was
euch glaube ich gut gefallen dürfte und
es werden demnächst wahrscheinlich die
ersten t shirts tatsächlich herauskommt
das hätte ich auch keine ahnung ich bin
schon so lange auf youtube eigentlich
also was ist so lange aber schon lange
leute das müsste ich mal geben jetzt
fast eineinhalb jahre
eineinviertel jahren über alle
vierteljahre das ist auch schon eine
menge
da wird es langsam zeit dass irgendwie
merchandise oder so was raus bringen hat
sich jetzt lange eine lange zeit
gelassen der liebe es reicht langsam und
dann habe ich mich ja jetzt so weit dass
raushauen
und deswegen kommt es dann in den
nächsten tagen wochen
wir haben aber noch kein fixes datum
überlebe ich den sprung da oder nicht
okay
das schaut ja nice und dann habe die
runde tatsächlich geworden was geht
gg man kriegt ja immer so eine
besetzerin pilz pur auf dem kopf jemand
village kurven kopf-an-kopf pilz weg ja
so ne nummer drei hat gestarteten wir
sind wieder auf der baum nein sie wenig
was erzähle ich denn sheen für mich als
wäre sie beim abheben soll für mich so
aus ist aber nicht der fall wissen auf
einer anderen website haben jetzt glaube
ich drei maps gesehen und hinter mir ist
einer ich höre den hier
okay ganz gut so weiter bis auf platz
eins aber nur ganz klein bisschen das
tmd friction hier lebten hier drüben ist
ein pilz was passiert da komme ich dahin
nicht glaube nicht dass knapp alter wo
es war konnte man nicht nur sprinten
ok jetzt habe ich ein problem jetzt habe
ich ein krasses problem und zwar das der
mich dahin alles klar
wenn du schon hinten dran bist dann mach
am besten eine sache und zwar bringt
sich selbst um
weil wir können immer noch in kenia kam
schon mit kernen flieg flieg so nah ist
immerhin immerhin habe noch einen kilt
das wird auch das gerät punkte gibt zwar
keine karma punkte aber egal ob er gut
depressionen auch schon vorbei gg okay
leute das war's von heute wie gesagt 20
uhr ist der stream
ja weil wir wissen und stelle ihr bis
zum bescheid würde mich freuen wenn
dreinschaut und schreib doch mal bitte
in die kommentare was ihr von den t
shirts hat würdet ihr euch die gerne zu
legen findet ihr so was toll und cool
wurde er wahr was euch durch den kopf
geht schreibt einfach mal rein wir sind
zunächst wieder wieder haut rein macht's
gut